>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good afternoon
and thank you all for coming.
I mean we have a very
special program today
and our speaker has come all
the way from Paris to be with us
and to share her research.
I want to welcome her and of course
to welcome Her Imperial
Highness the Shahbanou
who has been a great
supporter of this library,
supporter of our programs
and four years ago we had a
big exhibit on A Thousand Years
of the Persian Book and it
not been for Her Highness,
we would hot have been
able to make it.
She was-- she was there behind us.
She met with Dr. Billington
and said A Thousand Years
of the Persian Book, we
have to support this effort
and the whole Iranian-American
community rallied behind her
and were able to put
together the first
and the spectacular
exhibit of the Persian book.
So, I am Mary-Jane Deeb, Chief of
the African Middle East Division
and I'm here to welcome you
all and also as a reminder
that this division, with the
support of its members and--
who are scholars, writers, thinkers,
and people who have a deep interest
in the region, stand out and make a
program such as this one possible.
Dr. Layla Diba is a major scholar
in the arts and history of Iran
and she has an incredible career
which will be shared with you
in a moment, but I just wanted
to be here to express a--
my gratitude to those who have
supported us like Your Highness.
So, I am passing now the baton to
the head of the near east section
who is going to say a few
words of welcome as well.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you, Mary-Jane.
Good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen and particular Highness.
I'm thrilled to have you here today.
On behalf of all my colleagues, I'd
like to welcome you to the African
and Middle East Division and a
very warm welcome to everyone,
particularly about this program
Kamal al Mulk and the Invention
of the Modern Iranian Landscape.
But, before we start
today's program,
we always like to give our
newcomers a little overview.
I'm afraid some of
us have heard this
for every single program
they've been to, but we'd still
like to give everybody a little
welcome orientation to our division.
This is a custodial division,
which means that we actually
have the books in our purview,
in our custody, and this means
that we build and serve collections
to researchers from around the
world and we cover over 78 countries
and over two dozen languages.
The African section includes all of
the countries of Sub-Sahara Africa
and the Judaic or Hebraic
section covers Judaica worldwide
and the Near East section covers
all of the Arab countries,
including North Africa, Turkey,
Turkic Central Asia, Iran,
of course, and Afghanistan, and
the Muslims of Western China
and the peoples of the caucuses.
So, it's a very extensive region
and we hope you'll come back
and use our collections
for your research.
And just a couple notes
of housekeeping.
After the program, we invite
you to fill in our survey.
This helps us plan for
future programs and also we'd
like to invite you to try out
our Facebook and our blog.
We've left little papers so
you can easily find them.
Our curators are writing
very interesting blog posts
about special parts of the
collection and if you like us
on Facebook you'll find out about
all sorts of other programs.
So, please do that.
And also, just one last
thing, we'd like to remind you
that this program's being
videocast, so if you would
like to answer a quest--
ask a question, then you're
implicitly giving your permission
to be videotaped.
So, without further ado, I'd
like to call upon my colleague,
Hirad Dinavari, to
introduce the speaker.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank you, Joan.
Thank you, Mary-Jane.
Thank you everyone for coming
on a busy weekday and on
such a beautiful day where you could
probably be outside enjoying the
fresh weather.
We are very honored to have Her
Royal Highness Farah Diba here
with us.
Total surprise and shock and we are
very delighted that you're here,
thank you, and thank you
again personally for all
of your help with that exhibition.
It was not going to happen
without the help that you gave us.
We are also very happy
that every year for Nowruz,
the festival of spring that brings
together vast regions all the way
from Western China to the
Balkans, many, many nationalities
and many groups, Turkic and Iranian,
we do a cultural Nowruz
event every year.
It is a huge honor to have a curator
at the caliber of Dr. Layla Diba,
who has accepted to come here
and give this wonderful talk.
So, I am going to not take too
much time and Dr. Diba has a CV
that is very long and I will try
to give you a few highlights here
and then give the rest of
the time for her to speak.
Our Nowruz lecturer
figure, Dr. Layla Diba,
is an independent scholar,
arts advisor, and curator.
She has been the director
and chief curator
of the Negarestan Museum in Tehran.
Negarestan-- I'm sorry-- Negarestan
Museum in Tehran from 75 to 79.
Arts advisor for the
private secretariat
of Her Majesty Queen Farah Diba,
and the Hagop Kevorkian curator
of Islamic art at the
Brooklyn Museum of Art.
In 2006, Dr. Diba was invited to
develop programming and strategy
for the future of the Guggenheim's
Abu Dhabi Museum and to serve
on the museum's Asian Art Council
and the Middle East focus group.
She has curated the landmark--
the landmark The Qajar Epoch.
This is a book that
is really a textbook.
I have to tell you, as a librarian,
I have referred many
researchers including myself
to this book on Qajar painting.
So, The Qajar Epoch Royal
Persian Paintings exhibition
and the Brooklyn-- at the
Brooklyn Museum of Art.
This was an exhibit and
the book came with it.
The book itself is a treasure
trove of paintings that go back,
if I'm correct, to the
Afsharid period and it comes
down to the end of the Qajars.
It's wonderful book.
The list of accomplishments
go on and on and on.
I would just like to
come to the end and say
from the many articles she has
written that are scholarly,
that are published in
scholarly publications,
she also sits on the board
of Encyclopedia Iranica
and the Soudavar Memorial
Foundations.
She is also the collector of Persian
Islamic art and the benefactor
and the advocate of numerous
Persian cultural causes.
Current projects include a study
of Kamal al Mulk and the emergence
of Iranian landscape painting,
which we have the honor
of hearing her first
talk about this,
as this has been something
she's been working on,
and the emergence of-- I said that--
and articles and contemporary
Iranian artists like Shirin Neshat
and Nikzad Nojoomi as well.
So, without taking any further time,
thank you again for making time
to come down here and
see us and give a talk.
Please.
[ Applause ]
>> Layla Diba: Your
Majesty, honored guests.
Thank you to my colleagues from the
Library of Congress and to Hirad
for your kind words and
for inviting me to lecture
on this auspicious occasion
of the Persian new year.
I am delighted-- is there
light, by any chance?
Can I have more light?
OK. I'm delighted to speak about
Qajar art again in the presence
of Her Majesty Shahbanou Farah
who is the founder and patron
of the Negarestan Museum of 18th
and 19th century Iranian art,
which I had the honor to
direct from 1975 to 1978
and which really was the impetus
for a lifelong interest
and career in the arts.
Just for your information, since
this lecture really is a preview
of unpublished work, the text
and the images are copyrighted.
The recent discovery of a group of
six late 19th century Iranian oil
on canvas landscape
paintings and a large corpus
of 19th century Iranian photographs
held in a private collection outside
of Iran has provided the
impetus for today's lecture.
I wish to express my thanks
to the owners for permission
to present these works for
the first time to the public
and we hope they will be the subject
of a comprehensive
future publication.
The corpus of landscapes was
painted by the leading court painter
of the Nasiri era Mohammad Ghaffari
Kamal al Mulk, 1859 to 1922,
who was also the principal exponent
of European-style academic painting
in the late Qajar and
early Pahlavi eras.
Kamal al Mulk is perhaps best
known for his portraiture
and architectural views, but
my current research has led me
to conclude that he had an abiding
interest in the genre of landscape.
I will argue that these landscape
paintings present critical new
evidence for the development
of Kamal al Mulk's [inaudible]
and that they play a
significant role in the emergence
of the Iranian landscape of the
late Qajar and early Pahlavi eras.
A subject which has hitherto
been largely unexplored.
The works fall into two
chronological groups,
as you will see.
The first group features four views
of Iranian mountain landscapes dated
to the 1880's, which are among
his earliest known works.
The second group is comprised
of two European landscapes,
which may be assigned to
sometime between 1898 and 1901,
executed either in
Florence or in Paris,
both of which he lived
in at that time.
As a group, the paintings
are remarkably fresh
and largely unrecorded.
The landscapes and their
lengthy inscriptions
by Kamal al Mulk himself--
you can see on the lower left
or right there are like two,
three lines of inscriptions.
Giving details of date and
location provide the framework--
thank you so much--
for our discussion.
First, I will discuss
Nasiri court culture
in Kamal al Mulk's
career-- thank you so much.
Second, I will present an analysis
of Kamal al Mulk's landscapes
of the 1880's and his post-1900
landscapes and those of his school,
the [inaudible] Kamal al Mulk.
And, finally, consider
their significance
for the Iranian landscape tradition
and the birth of Iranian modernism.
So, first, Nasiri court
culture, the setting.
Court culture of the era of
Nassereddin Shah, 1848 to 1896,
was dominated by the will and whims
of the autocratic ruler and centered
in the Golestan Palace, the
site of a precarious balance
between Persian tradition
and European modernity.
Certain features pertain
directly to the production
of the landscape corpus
under discussion.
The era was marked
by the introductions
and enthusiastic acceptance
of photography.
Students were sent abroad to
study, particularly to Paris,
and a European academy-style
art curriculum was taught
at the Dar ul-Funun, the royal
military college, as of 1862.
The role-- the ruler created a
museum for his collection as well
as designated galleries within
the premises of the palace.
He founded also an office
of publication and printing
for a vast program of
historical and scientific texts,
European translations, and
the Royal Court Gazette.
These innovations served to
enforce the power of the Shah
by presenting an image of a
modern and effective ruler
and by mapping his territories
and recording information
on his subjects.
In these endeavors, he was assisted
by a vast array of courtiers
and ministries, many
of whom were invested
in introducing European culture,
technology, and eventually reforms.
These institutions were
accompanied by court activities
such as yearly European-style
exhibitions of artists' work modeled
on the Salon d'Automne in Paris
and more traditional
Persian kingly pursuits
such as court entertainment,
visits to the harem, hunting trips,
and more rarely military
expeditions.
The Dar ul-Funun housed both
photographic and painting studios,
both of which would have been known
to Kamal al Mulk during his
formative years as a court artist.
Thousands of photographs produced
for the court have survived.
Although the portraits and images
of archeological sites are the
most well-know of the photographs,
three previously unknown
court stereophotographs,
of which you see one on the
screen, of the Iranian landscape
and royal encampments which
were commissioned by the rule
from the court photographer
[inaudible]
in the 1860's have
recently been published
and these you see on the screen.
The photographs are
inscribed by the ruler
and by Ali Reza [assumed
spelling] and give the locations
of [inaudible] and
Aliabad as the sites.
Unfortunately, further evidence
from Golestan collections
remains unpublished.
However, now another very
large corpus of photographs
and landscape photographs outside
of Iran has been brought
to my attention.
The three photographs serve
as intriguing precedents
for the landscapes
painted by Kamal al Mulk
with almost photographic
realism in the 1880's.
More interestingly,
the new photographs,
which I will discuss again
shortly, are even closer in date
to Kamal al Mulk's landscapes.
As you can see, it's dated 1870's.
Information on landscape painting
at the Dar ul-Funun is sparse
and we need to open a parenthesis
on the development of this genre
in Persian painting
before Kamal al Mulk.
Until the mid-17th century
when European painting influenced
Persian painting traditions,
the Persian landscape was
depicted in manuscripts in flat,
decorative, and semiabstract style.
Then European-style landscapes
with modeling and recession,
chiefly associated with the court
painter Mohamad Aman became the
vogue for manuscript painting and
lacquer work of the 17th century.
The next development does not
occur until the mid-19th century.
Landscape backgrounds of Sani'
al-Mulk's watercolor illustrations
for the Thousand and One
Nights manuscript, about 1853.
When we see a new infusion of
European painting techniques,
there may also have been an
awareness of European landscapes
through the interaction
of Iranian artists
with European artist diplomats and
officers such as Colonel Colombari
who flocked to Iran during
the mid- to late-19th century.
However, the interest
in pure landscape seems
to have been only limited since only
a single painting with a landscape
by Kamal al Mulk's
teacher has survived.
Kamal al Mulk's Iranian landscapes
would never have been produced
without the ruler's patronage, which
encouraged competition and rivalry
between bazaar craftsman, court
painters, and photographer.
Another factor was probably
the publication program
of Mohammad-Hasan Khan E'temad
al-Saltaneh, the court chronicler
and chief minister for publication.
In addition to histories
of the reign,
the ruler commissioned
historical geographies of Khorasan,
such as the [inaudible] and the most
likely candidate for the context
of Kamal al Mulk's
Iranian landscape,
the historical geographic
dictionary, Mirat-ul-Buldan.
This work was based on
E'temad's data and observation
of the provinces collected in the
1880's on the order of the Shah.
As recently noted by Abbas
Amanat, this project was informed
by a new awareness of
topography and the boundaries
of Persia as a national entity.
These developments occurred after
the Shah's first two trips to Europe
in 1873 and 1878 and reflect the
ruler's awareness of the importance
of documenting and controlling his
domains vis a vis those he had seen.
Kamal al Mulk's ascendency as
a court artist and confidant
of the ruler would coincide
with these programs.
So, we will look at his career
from the 1870's to 1901,
which is the framework
of our paintings.
Kamal al Mulk was born
in 1859 to a family
of prominent courtier statesman
and artists from Kashan.
His early training as an artist
began with apprenticeship
with his uncle, Abolhassan Ghaffari
Sani' al-Mulk, chief court painter
of Muhammad and Nassereddin Shahs,
who had received training in Italy
in classical painting and in the
use of the lithographic press.
Sani' al-Mulk became a
teacher at the Dar ul-Funun,
where prints of old master paintings
and plaster casts he
had brought back
from Europe were part
of the curriculum.
Sani' al-Mulk was also editor
of the illustrated Court Gazette
and recipient of major
commissions such as the Thousand
and One Nights manuscript
and the [inaudible] wall
paintings of the Nasiri court.
After the death of
his uncle in 1866,
Kamal al Mulk continued his studies
at the Dar ul-Funun for eight years.
During the 1870's,
he studied painting
with Mirza Ali Akbar
Mozayyen-od-Doleh,
also born in Kashan, who was
Sani' al-Mulk's successor
at the Dar ul-Funun.
Mozayyen-od-Doleh was a
graduate or the only graduate
of the Academie des
Beaux-Arts in Paris,
which he frequented in the 1850's.
He faithfully applied the
methods of the French academy
and probably retained aspects
of the curriculum already
introduced by Sani' al-Mulk.
Kamal al Mulk maintained
that Mozayyen-od-Doleh quote unquote
was a trained artist in academic art
and that quote I learned the art
of painting from no one by myself.
A still life you see on this
screen dated 1907-8 and a copy
of the mid-19th century French
artist Rosa Bonheur's iconic
painting attests to
this artist's skills.
As evidenced by the landscape
which you see in the background
of the painting Ploughing Time,
Mozayyen-od-Doleh's
landscapes were composed after
and closely followed European models
painted in the artist's studio.
OK? This is very important that
they are copied from other versions
that were actually
painted in the studio.
And these confirm Kamal al Mulk's
statement and the originality
of Kamal al Mulk's
open-air practice,
which you will see in a few minutes.
Now, Kamal al Mulk's skill soon
caught the attention of the Shah
who appointed him one of his
personal attendants and, in 1881,
court painter [inaudible].
During the following years until
the ruler's assassination in 1896,
Kamal al Mulk executed portraits
of the ruler, such as you saw
at the beginning, the famous hall of
mirrors, and of the court, palace,
and of the court notables and
landscape views that surpassed all
of his contemporary in their
almost photographic naturalism,
attention to detail,
and color sense.
His renderings of the hall of
mirrors, the Takiya-ye Dawlat
and the [inaudible] are
considered among his masterpieces,
yet he also showed an
interest in genre scenes set
in contemporary urban settings
such as his paintings
of geomancers and women.
Kamal al Mulk appears to
have accompanied the ruler
on his trips throughout the
provinces and this is a major theory
that we have been developing--
I've been developing thanks
to this close scrutiny
of this group of paintings.
So, the idea that Kamal al Mulk
accompanied the ruler throughout the
providence and his landscape and
encampment scenes, which you'll see,
were executed en plein air.
The only artist of his
era to have done so.
Photography did play a
role in his practice,
particularly in portraiture
and memorial portraits,
but it was his extraordinary skill
as a painter which is revealed
in the works he produced in
the decades when he was working
for the court, including the
landscapes under consideration.
His great painterly skills were
thus evident even before his trip
to Europe where he would
study the old masters
and modern painters directly.
A year and a half after
the ruler's death,
Kamal al Mulk requested permission
to go to Europe to study.
He remained there for a very
long time, for about three years.
According to his memoirs,
he studied first in Florence
with the royal portrait
painter Michele Gordigiani,
who was active until 1909.
Now, Gordigiani is a
documented painter.
He was academic in training,
but with a [inaudible]
for naturalism known in Italy
as the Macchiaioli movement.
Kamal al Mulk expresses his
admiration for the style
of naturalism in addition to
his better-known appreciation
of the old masters in his memoirs.
Now, as a parenthesis,
what was naturalism?
It was a mid- to late-19th
century European cultural
and literary movement which
originated in France with the works
of Emile Zola and included painters
such as Courbet at the beginning.
It was contemporary with
impressionism and it espoused a form
of heightened realism with social
political awareness that was lacking
in the light-hearted
scenes of picnics
and open-air entertainments
favored by the impressionists.
So, given Kamal al Mulk's
support of the constitutionalists,
the [foreign phrase] or
intellectuals and of freemasonry,
it seemed logical he would be drawn
to this movement, which
he encountered.
Now, back to Gordigiani.
He was the official Italian court
painter and although he seems
to have appreciated Kamal al
Mulk's talents, he also abused it,
according to the painter
who claimed in his memoirs
that Gordigiani passed off as his
own work this portrait of the ruler
of Siam, which was actually
painted by Kamal al Mulk.
And, believe it or not, my assistant
actually located this painting
on the internet.
We have no idea where it is,
but the idea that there is a
Kamal al Mulk original out there
that I don't know who signed it,
I assume it has the signature
of Gordigiani in it,
but in his memoirs,
Kamal al Mulk says
that he painted this.
So, those are the vagaries of
being a student of a great master.
After a year and a half,
Kamal al Mulk went on to Paris
where he rented a studio in the
artist's quarter and copied works
of the old masters such as
Rembrandt and Titian in the Louvre.
He also copied Italian
landscapes and executed portraits
of his fellow artists such
as Henri Fantin-Latour,
the French realist painter, and a
series of remarkable self-portraits.
His main achievement, in my view, in
Europe was to perfect his knowledge
of the techniques of illusionistic
painting, which he had learned
through his own practice
in Iran previously,
and to familiarize himself
with the theories on naturalism
and literature and art, which were
in vogue in that time in Europe.
Although Kamal al Mulk worked
as a court painter for a year,
on his return to Iran, he did
not like Mozaffar ad-Din Shah
or his questionable taste in art,
so Kamal al Mulk retired himself
to Baghdad and Karbala
for over two years.
It is from this period that a
shift in subject matter occurs
with greater attention paid
to urban scenes and images
of the everyday life
of ordinary people.
This represented a major
evolution in the visual language
of Persian painting and
would have a lasting effect
on its subsequent development.
The following analysis will discuss
the role of landscape painting
in the chronological
evolution of his practice
and highlight the significance
of this new genre, landscape,
for modern Iranian painting.
The first group of mountainous
landscape was painted circa 1882
and 1883, but I've not made a
finalized reading of all the dates.
These years coincide with
Kamal al Mulk's early years
as a court artist.
Analysis of the iconography,
topography, and inscriptions
of these works confirm they
were most likely executed
when he accompanied the ruler on
his frequent trips to the provinces.
The inscriptions provide many
locations from the area of Tehran
and Mazandaran and I want to thank
my research assistant Layah Bigdeli
for creating this map of all
the locations of his paintings.
The inscriptions, which
conform in style with those
of his other published
inscribed works,
do not specifically
mention a royal commission.
Meaning there is never the
phrase [foreign language].
OK? To the order of.
However, numerous trips by the
ruler to this area are recorded
by E'temad al-Saltaneh in his daily
journal by year, day, and month.
So, the entries coincide
approximately
with the locations given in the
works themselves, which is--
yes, it's like a goldmine for an
art historian to be able to do that.
So, all the works are
painted in rectangular format
from a high viewpoint which
would provide a panoramic view
of the valley and of the mountains.
In order to analyze the
relationship between photography
and Kamal al Mulk's practice,
comparison with the larger corpus
of landscape photographs from
the previously mentioned private
collection and from the
Golestan is needed, but--
which is beyond the
parameters of today's talk.
So, what I've done is with a single
comparison between this image
and this early photograph, these
are both views of the same site
and this we know from
reading the inscriptions.
A location called Kayvan Shokoh
[assumed spelling], an encampment.
So, you see Kamal al Mulk's painting
and the photograph
of the same location.
We see how his choice
differentiates his work
from the published images taken
by the court photographers.
You can see the photographs
are square format close ups
of anecdotal scenes with
the landscape barely visible
in the background.
So, a completely different
approach and concern
from that of the painter.
The compositions are dominated by
rolling hills and mountain foothills
in the background and feature
verdant valleys in the middle ground
and dark, rocky outcrops
in the foreground.
Three of the paintings
show large tent encampments
in the middle ground.
The scale of the encampments
and the presence
of red textile partitions separating
off the main tent indicate these are
royal encampments.
The View of the Bend on the
River, which you see here,
features a wandering river and
groups of trees on the hillsides
as well as small retainers in black
in the foreground and a mule train
which gives scale to
the whole scene.
A View of [inaudible] depicts
a small village clinging
to the mountainside with an
[inaudible] in the foreground
and gardens and houses
in the very front.
As a rule, the foreground acts
as a repertoire and the rules
of landscape recession, modeling,
perspective, aerial recession,
and the direction of light
are faithfully observed
in the artist's treatment
of the hills.
Careful attention is paid
to detailed rendering
also of vegetation.
Sometimes green and
dotted with trees.
Sometimes arid and craggy.
And to do the texture
of the rough earth.
The contrast between green
and arid areas is typical
of the Iranian landscape
between Tehran and the Caspian,
a favorite area for picnicking
and more prolonged country stays.
The palette is also earthy.
Terracotta and olive green
shot through with white.
Crystal clear blue is used
for the water and the sky.
The minute white tents with
their pointed tops are scattered
across the landscape as so many
exclamation points is our small
black figures and animals.
The paintings have a roughly
sketchy surface, not highly polished
and finished, as if the artist
wanted to capture the immediacy
and specificity of his experience.
This is confirmed by
the inscriptions
which give the exact direction
of the artist's viewpoint.
This is so remarkable.
He says it's taken from the north,
it shows the east and the west,
it's the view through this valley.
So, these inscriptions-- the reading
of these inscriptions
is very critical.
The careful realism and photographic
details suggest these paintings may
have had a scientific or
illustrative purpose linked
to the ruler's previously
discussed policy of recording
and surveying his domains
and to E'temad al-Saltaneh's
numerous publications.
This is entirely theoretical,
but we need--
we need to have some theory here.
Now, let us review the
evidence of this group in light
of the artist's known
landscape [inaudible].
With this discovery, four new
works are added to the corpus
of 37 landscapes currently
known and these are all listed--
I wrote a joint article with
Ahmad Ashraf on Kamal al Mulk
in the Encyclopedia Iranica.
Dr. Ashraf really did
the very hard work
of listing almost every
known work of Kamal al Mulk.
For those of you who
would like to go further.
So, at that point, there
were 37 landscapes.
So, now we added four more
to these, plus another six.
The four works we just discussed
in conjunction with a few others
from the decades before
Kamal al Mulk went
to Europe illustrate the
painter's increasing skill
in composition in painting
technique.
So, you can see the artist learning
and teaching himself and get--
this is 1888, about four years
later than the early ones,
and you can really see the
amazing progress he's made.
By the late 1880's, Kamal al Mulk's
landscape become more monumental
and awe-inspiring, not
unlike the paintings
of the Hudson River School
capturing the majesty
of the Alborz mountain
range and the sharp contrast
with the plains and plateaus below.
By 1891, his focus has turned to
the human element in the landscape.
In his depiction of
a tent encampment,
which you see on the screen,
which pre-stages the artist's
more naturalistic approach
after his return from Europe.
I now turn to the two
Italianate landscapes
which share sufficient
features to have been painted
at the same time and place.
One is signed and dated
1898-99, [inaudible] 1316,
and the other bears an inscription.
A very interesting inscription
which states it was copied
from an Italian painting
and given in exchange
for a work to another painter.
So, his inscriptions are
incredibly chatty and informative
about even the relations
between artists and none
of this is currently known or
recorded in the study of his work.
This episode between painters could
have occurred in either Florence
or Paris since the dates
bridge the time in both cities.
Stylistically, the
paintings share many feature
with Jean-Baptiste Camille
Corot, whose work you see
on the screen compared
with Kamal al Mulk's work.
Italian landscapes by Corot
such-- and you see, as I said,
the comparison is when
Corot visited Italy.
And you see similarities such as the
focus on the bridges and aqueducts,
the style of the houses, the
flat treatment of the surface,
and the attention to light.
These are all new.
However, an exact model remains
to be identified, but I haven't
yet gone through every single one
of Corot's thousands of paintings,
so I'm still hopeful,
but this is very close.
The prototype could also
have been, we must admit,
by a later Italian
follower of Corot's style.
Although Corot was active earlier in
the 19th century than Kamal al Mulk,
he was still extremely popular
at the turn of the century
and would have been held up to
the painter as a worthy model
of western landscape
painting to emulate.
As was the case with
the four previous works,
the two Italian landscape--
and here is the second one--
I have identified this as an Italian
landscape based on the vegetation
and the presence of the
church in the middle ground.
They also document a key moment
in Kamal al Mulk's evolution.
After his European trip,
he continued to paint
landscapes until the 1920's.
There are-- these are
considerably looser in brush work
with a softer palette
and so fused with light
and air compared to
his earlier attempts.
The two Italian landscapes
illustrate just how he got there.
How do we get from here to there?
We may now asset that in all Kamal
al Mulk painted over 42 landscapes,
a considerable portion of his
[inaudible] throughout his career.
Now we pass finally to
the last part of my talk,
the invention of an
Iranian landscape.
The introduction and
development of the new genre
of European-style landscape
painting is a neglected aspect
of Kamal al Mulk's contribution
to modern Iranian art.
The importance of his legacy,
which can be seen in the works
of his followers who studied
with him at the famous school
that Kamal al Mulk directed
for a very long time
in the early 20th century.
And, principally, Ali
Mohammad Heydarian.
Here on the screen, you see a work
by Ghaffari and a work by Heydarian.
It is worth noting that
besides Kamal al Mulk's school,
which again you see--
with this comparison,
you can see how much
influence Heydarian
and how closely he followed him--
besides the school of Kamal al Mulk,
there was also some
proponents of the school
of Europeanate [phonetic] landscape
style, but this time channeled
through Russian 19th
century painting.
This was passed on
by the Rashti artist
and teacher Sayed Mohammed Habib
Mohammedi [assumed spelling]
and by another painter, Hod
Hussain Rasadi [assumed spelling]
to a new generation of artists
who were to become the pioneers
of modernism, such as [inaudible],
Nikzad Nojoomi, and [inaudible]
who were all students of Mohammedi.
In conclusion, Kamal al Mulk's early
landscape paintings may be seen
as part of experiments
and documentation
for the court enterprise of
recording and presenting an image
of Qajar Iran, an image based on,
they thought, empirical evidence.
When viewed in conjunction with
his later landscape paintings,
they also reveal to
be-- Kamal al Mulk
to be the truly innovative
artist he claimed to be.
So, I view even artist's memoirs
with skepticism, but, in this case,
we I think confirm that indeed
how innovative he was early
in his career.
The only known painter
of his generation
to compose his paintings outside
the studio is really remarkable.
Equally important, the
Italianate works form a bridge
to his later landscapes using
a more modern visual language.
Hopefully we have advanced
our understanding
of later Persian painting and
its art historical issues.
These paintings are key works in
the evolution of Kamal al Mulk
from academic painting for the
court to naturalist paining
of Iranian modern life which was
to have the most profound influence
on the course of Iranian modern art.
The formation of Iranian modern art
involved not only European stylistic
and iconographic conventions,
but the introduction
of new subject matter and genre
such as the realistic portrait
and what we've been discussing
today, the independent landscapes;
both of which would
have been impossible
without the genius of Kamal al Mulk.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you, Dr. Diba.
We have room for some questions.
Feel free to ask.
>> That was good.
Thank you very much.
I mean that was very exciting
and it was an eye-opener.
I wanted to ask you his painting
was primarily the landscape
in rural areas.
Did he do anything in the city?
Did he--
>> Layla Diba: Yes.
>> Major cities in Iran.
Did he try to convey as--
>> Layla Diba: Well, almost
everything he did in the beginning
of his career was to
record the architecture
of the Golestan Palace complex
and so there are many views
of the architecture and the
different buildings in the--
and I showed one, which-- and they
were extraordinary for the era,
but it's interesting, as
I said, when he had the--
he was no longer an official court
painter that he went to Karbala
and Najaf and he painted
scenes of those modest towns
and squares and the people.
So, he began going
beyond the parameters
of the court certainly by 1900.
And this continued much more
strongly after he returned
from Europe and I think
this broadening
of subject matter beyond the court
to a more modern kind of interest
in the-- in his own time.
I think you see it evolving
and it becomes much stronger
in the early 20th century.
So, yes, there are many,
many urban city views.
Yes. Her Majesty.
>> Farah Pahlavi: Didn't he paint
also a lot of people and musicians?
>> Layla Diba: Oh, yes.
Yes, yes. I mean his-- he's
primarily known for his portraiture
and they're remarkable,
the court musicians,
the court personalities,
and they're so incisive.
People, you know, mention
photography
because they're so realistic.
I think the most interesting
things he did was a series
of self-portraits, which
again was completely--
no Iranian painter ever had the
temerity to use himself as a subject
and there are like
six self-portraits
and he greatly admired Rembrandt.
So, I think, you know, his interest
in portraiture once he got to Europe
and the Louvre-- and
you saw Rembrandts,
but his skill as a painter-- and I
think he was interested in humanity
and personality and many of his
greatest works are portraits.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Yes, please.
>> Farah Pahlavi: You know, because
you're a scholar, where did you find
out all the story about his life,
going to Europe, [inaudible].
>> Layla Diba: Well, there-- yes.
There is a-- there is a--
I wouldn't say enormous,
but a substantial bibliography
and I was mentioning
earlier well before I came
to the field there was a
scholar called Sohali Honsari
[assumed spelling].
You may remember him, Your Majesty.
And he wrote a very
comprehensive book on Kamal al Mulk
and reproduced many of the works
and I can base a lot of my remarks
on that book, but also
amazingly, again,
Kamal al Mulk himself left his
memoirs, wrote about 10 pages
in his own hand and these
were published in the memoirs
of Dr. Ghasem Ghani,
Cyrus Ghani's father,
which Cyrus then published
in eight volumes.
So, we have the painter's own
account and when I read these,
I was reading the name of
this painter, Gordigiani,
I said this can't be right.
You know? He must have
misunderstood.
How could-- what a strange name,
gorgeous dawn, you know, Florence,
but I went-- there--
you know, there are--
there are books of famous
artists, Tina Becker is known
as the bible of-- every
artist is listed--
and Kamal al Mulk gave
the correct spelling
and then we tracked this down.
So, his own memoirs are
a very valuable resource
that scholars have not used
enough and they didn't realize--
I mean there are incredible
nuggets in there and he talks
about his relationship with
the ruler and he was accused
at one point of stealing something
from the [inaudible] because--
I mean it was very
personal and so his memoirs,
even though they are 10
pages long, they're very,
very informative about his life.
But-- so, there's been
a lot of scholarship.
I would actually use this occasion
to mention something that is a plea.
In my work on this, because I was--
I am not able to go back to Iran.
I do not wish to.
I have to rely on printed
publications and, unfortunately,
the quality of the color makes it
very difficult to draw conclusions
and so for the advancement of not
my work, but just the advancement
of history, if you look, I chose
a page from Heydarian's book,
but there are other books where the
colors are completely different.
Completely.
And so it's a matter of-- for
scholars and connoisseurs worldwide
who really want to know what
Kamal al Mulk's paintings look
like who cannot go to Iran,
they need to publish things
that are accurate in color.
So, I'm still very careful
about what I say in terms
of his later work and of all his
work, which is why this group
of paintings which I could
examine personally and I know
that the colors are right
and the inscriptions are
correctly read and so on.
But I hope very much our Iranian
colleagues will understand how
important this would be
and they will publish--
they're almost all in
the Golestan Palace.
Some in the Malek Library,
which is nice,
but they really need better
printing and it's 30 year--
well, yeah, 1896, at least 20--
1996 I think is when
Sohali's book was printed.
Yes, sir. Yes.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Oh really?
Yes.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Oh, really?
What was his first name?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Title. Yes.
You know, there is all-- there
is really nothing published
on other painters of the Iranian
landscape, which why I'm careful
to say this is a work in progress.
I think many of them
were destroyed during the
constitutional revolution.
Many of them I think were created
for patrons who had mansions
and palaces in Tehran that
were just, you know, ransacked.
Because none of them are published.
And so this is a huge gap.
So, we need to use history
and anecdote to fill this
in a little bit and
hopefully Iranian families
who have paintings--
family paintings--
may eventually make them available
and as your comment is
something one can follow up.
We do know, actually, the
names of many of the students
in Kamal al Mulk's
school, but we don't know
which of them painted landscapes,
but you'll get my brain working.
Pardon?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Well, I think at the-- it may
be privately, as you said.
There is-- there is a source
which I haven't referred
to because I've got
to find it again.
It's by [inaudible] and he
wrote a short two-page history
of the artists of Nassereddin
Shah and, in my next lecture,
I believe he refers to
landscape paintings,
but we have no surviving examples.
So-- you have some?
No? You're just going
I wish I had some.
But I believe in the potential of
research and I hope young scholars
and more-- through more
dialogues like this one,
we just need to unearth, you
know, archeologically sort
of unearth this information
that's held in family archives,
family memories-- because
it's very recent memory.
We're talking about 1920's, 1930's.
So, really, I'm grateful
to learn about any painters
and hopefully we can
follow up and we need
to note the existence, absolutely.
Absolutely.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank you.
Go ahead, Simon.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Layla Diba: No.
No. By now, no.
No. I mean he really stopped
painting for royal patrons
by about 1900 and then he
founded his own school.
He-- his patrons were
mainly constitutionalists
and ministers and, you know, the
grandees of the constitutional era.
Because he was a constitutionalist
himself and so--
no, I mean for instance he
never painted a portrait
of Ahmad Shah, I don't think.
I think he-- the last one he
painted would have been Mozaffar
ad-Din Shah.
So, in my article and in
various places, I've mentioned--
and many of the, you know,
the portraits are inscribed.
In my article, in Iran modern,
there's a painting of Hakim al-Molk.
He was minister of
education, I think.
So, the patronage shifts and
then when he has his own school,
as I said, it's very
interesting to see an interest
in the common people,
in ordinary people.
Those weren't made for a patron.
Right? He was an artist and
he was a 20th century artist.
That's why I call him the
painter of modern Persian life
because even his personality
was amazing and very modern.
So, I think he was
an independent artist
and the later patrons
throughout his life--
and he was always commissioned, but,
you know, his eyesight began failing
and then he was no longer
director of the school,
so we know his patrons I would say
from the first two decades
of the 20th century.
Does that answer?
Too long, eh?
>> Hirad Dinavari: The name Kamal
al Mulk to me is an honorific title.
>> Layla Diba: Yes.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Is this something
that was given to him and he ended
up keeping it or did
he at some point revert
to what his birth name was?
I'm just curious.
>> Layla Diba: That's a--
that's a great question.
Absolute great question.
I'd have to study all his inscribed
works to answer that, but--
and, you know, I mean we
look at that very carefully
because it helps us to date
and create the context.
I mean you can see that, you know,
he will sign first
Mohammad Ghaffari.
Then Mohammad Ghaffari [inaudible].
Then Mohammad Ghaffari Kamal
al Mulk or [inaudible].
Or-- there's a whole vocabulary
of the artist's signatures
which explain his titles and I do--
I would actually love to know
what happened later in his career.
How did he sign his works?
But, as I said, one of-- you know,
I would really need to collaborate
with a colleague in Iran or
someone who could go to Iran
because it's very primary research.
You're going to have to go
and look at those inscriptions
which are not visible and it's not--
you know, the research interests
we have today are very different
from scholars of a generation ago.
The questions we ask.
We have to go find
the answers ourselves.
That's your job.
Yes, certain.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
I have a question.
You know, in different parts of the
Middle East, for example in Turkey,
in Egypt, in [inaudible] and other
parts, you had western artists
who came and then they settled
there and then they had an influence
on the painters and the community.
Was that the case then
in the beginning
of the century-- of
the 19th century?
>> Layla Diba: Very, very tenuous.
I mentioned that-- very
difficult to document.
I suggest that, you know, there
are some things you still have
to suggest.
I was very curious that none
of the Iranian scholars mentioned
these painter diplomats who were
in Iran and some of them
were very well-known,
Jean Laurent was a very well-known
19th century French painter
and great books of [foreign phrase].
So, there were European
painters-- and this Colombari,
there's a whole book of his works.
So, there's no-- so far-- so far, no
historical record of the encounters,
but I would think they
could be there.
But I did look through E'temad
al-Saltaneh's index to see
if he mentions any
European painters.
He doesn't.
So, I think, you know, there's
still a great deal of research
that would answer that question.
How do we explain Kamal al Mulk
doing this kind of painting?
Mozayyen-od-Doleh, you know,
nobody knows about this man.
He was such an important figure.
He was the painter, you know, the
chief teacher at the Dar ul-Funun.
All his work is gone.
He studied in Paris, he went to
the Beaux-Arts, he went to the--
he actually went to the-- studied
in the studio of [inaudible].
So, there-- yeah!
But we only have one painting left.
Two paintings, maybe, and
they appeared out of nowhere.
So, we don't-- we don't-- you
know, the evidence is so sparse,
Dr. Deeb, but it's there.
You know, one can hypothesize both--
but that's why I'm saying, well,
Kamal al Mulk was an
original because we don't know
who he learned this from,
but the other aspect is
that the Nassereddin Shah by the
1880's had come back from Europe,
he brought European
paintings with him,
and some of these have
been published.
I'm sure Her Majesty
remembers these--
they were 19-20th century
paintings in the Golestan Palace
and I'm sure some of them
were in the other buildings
in [inaudible] and so on.
And so my assumption is
that Kamal al Mulk looked
at those very carefully.
Taught himself.
But it's-- he never says it.
All he says is that I taught myself.
>> Hirad Dinavari: I'm curious,
continuing with what Mary-Jane
just asked, Russian and Armenian--
which is not quite European,
but a bridge between the two
because there was the Russian and
Armenian connection also happening
at this time with the
west-- more western-- yeah.
>> Layla Diba: I've
also studied that.
I have an article coming
out on that,
but that's why I mention
this painter Mohammedi.
He was-- who knew?
One painter in Rasht.
In Rasht! Yes!
He was a teacher of [inaudible]
and [inaudible] and Nojoomi!
Nojoomi actually talked
about another one in Hamadan.
These painters-- again,
because Kamal al Mulk
overshadowed everybody else,
so my job is a little bit to,
you know, give some attention
to the other currents
and other painters
and certainly Mohammedi
was trained in Russia.
I know-- I know that for a fact.
And so this other-- that's why
I mentioned that this other form
of landscape painting
and of modernism filtered
through Russia is part--
is a chapter in the history
of Iranian modernism.
Not one we can go into
today, but it was--
it's interesting that there were
these two channels of, you know,
influence that could come
via France, Germany, Russia.
So--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Well, you know, after World War II,
Iranian artists wanted to be modern.
So, it was cubism, cubism, cubism.
You know? They went to Paris and
especially [inaudible] came back
and Kamal al Mulk fell
into disfavor.
And also what's really
remarkable is the Iranian--
the level of discourse among Iranian
art critics, painters, artists,
and they got very heated arguments
over what Iranian modern
painting should be.
And Kamal al Mulk who had
been so revered as the father
of Iranian modernism was then
accused of just, you know,
being an imitator and
he fell into disfavor.
Because they were trying to find
a new path, yeah, but, you know,
we as historians, we look back
and that's why I kept saying
how innovative he was.
Of course he's so well-known, but
he also did some remarkable things
that we can now reaffirm.
But certainly I do--
and I've written this--
you know, his students
were not on his level.
You know? Nobody could equal
Kamal al Mulk and neither--
and we've looked at, you know,
Heydarian and there are books
about the school of Kamal al Mulk.
They were competent
painters, but none of them had
that drive, that passion.
I mean Kamal al Mulk, you know,
it was that passion to learn
and to teach himself to paint and
then to transmit it to others.
But-- so I think if there had been
another great painter among his
students of his stature, his style
of painting would have continued
longer, but I'm sorry the other half
of the equation is the revival
of interest in [inaudible].
So, these two collided and
that began in the 1920's,
1930's under Reza Shah
and artists begin painting
in the 17th century miniature style.
So, you had these two competing
currents going on for 20, 30 years
and then, you know,
abstract painting and cubism.
So, his influence--
but I wanted to say
that his influence was very strong.
Let's look again at Heydarian.
Let's look again at
his other followers.
That's very interesting.
Yes. That's a very interesting kind
of leap, but I would have to go back
and see-- I don't remember
[inaudible] speaking
about Kamal al Mulk.
Some of the artists did
and there have been--
as part of the more recent
literature, scholars have written
about all these arguments
about Kamal al Mulk
and what he was responsible
for, but I--
so, people like Marcos Grigorian
wrote against Kamal al Mulk,
you know, and others-- I mean huge
battles that are all recorded really
in Ahmad Ashraf's section
of this article.
So, I do think that there's
a lot more to try and look at
and I thank you for the
reference to [inaudible] who's--
really was another
landscape painter.
One painter I studied
very closely was Yektai
and Yektai actually knew Kamal
al Mulk and told me that he went
with his mother to
Kamal al Mulk's home.
I mean there are amazing
connections.
So, hopefully for another time.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Well, folks,
it's getting a little late
and most people have to go
back to their work and offices.
Again, thank you so much for making
the trip, coming here, and visiting
and giving this amazing--
[ Applause ]
>> Layla Diba: Thank you
to my wonderful audience
and their questions.
I loved it.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Absolutely.
>> Farah Pahlavi: And
we're very proud of Layla.
She's not like all Iranian
Americans that are exiled here.
She is really half-American
half-Iranian
and so the result has
become very important for us
in Iran before what happened and
even now we're very proud of you.
And also-- and I don't know if I
have a few minutes for Negarestan.
OK. Yeah, no, because Layla was
the head of Negarestan Museum and--
no, sorry-- and the story
of these other paintings is
that there was a collection
belonging
to Mr. Amery [assumed spelling]
in London and he proposed to us
to sell 100 other paintings
for $1 million.
So, I asked the ministry of
culture to send a few people
to see if they're OK or not.
It took so long that I heard that
Amery gave it to [inaudible].
I was in Switzerland.
When I heard that, I really cried.
I had tears in my eyes.
The head of my office was there.
I said please go to them and tell
them we cannot come to [inaudible]
and still-- and one by one buy--
this is a museum and so and--
and thankfully Amery
accepted and [inaudible] also.
Of course, we had to pay a little
more, so the Negarestan Museum was
in an old palace which belonged
to the queen mother in Tehran
and Professor [inaudible],
which was a Czech artist
which had arranged every room for
different paintings, portraits,
landscape, and Layla fortunately
was the curator and the--
it was a beautiful museum and when
the famous revolution happened
in Iran, these people made this
museum the house of the guardians
of the revolution as if there was
no building in Tehran such ages ago.
God knows where they have
sent these paintings.
Anyway, I wanted to say that about
the [inaudible] and thank you,
Layla, for what you have done
and there are books published
about those paintings.
And thank you for--
[ Applause ]
>> Layla Diba: I have a surprise.
Yes. Well, it's been
a great boon for me.
If you remember, I kept
saying I need to find the date
of the inauguration of the
museum and we asked the queen
and we asked our friends, we
asked other people, we couldn't--
nobody could remember, including me.
I said, well, I think
it's like June, July--
today, at the Library of Congress,
in the microfilm department,
I have found the front page
of Keyhan International
with your photograph with little
me and Queen Sophia of Greece.
April 13, 1975.
[ Applause ]
I was off by two months
and then I kept saying,
well, it's got to be earlier.
It's got to be-- April 13.
Actually, two days from now.
You were in Tehran-- yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
So, we now know.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Exactly.
>> Farah Pahlavi: I have
to tell you another story.
>> Layla Diba: Please.
>> Farah Pahlavi: Many years ago,
of course, after what happened,
they wrote in a French magazine
that I have taken some of the jewels
of the [inaudible] with me.
I knew that it was enough to
[inaudible] one of the newspapers
in Iran that the direction
of the [inaudible].
I asked a friend of mine and
a member of my family to come
to the Library of Congress
find the article--
she did and she copied and I
sent it back to the newspaper.
So, thank you Library of Congress.
>> Layla Diba: Thank
you, Library of Congress.
Thank you.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
You're very welcome.
Wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Thanks again, everyone, for coming.
Have a wonderful day.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.